[Applause]
good to have you here sir yes
a lot of palpable excitement about
pineapple express
i can feel it yes
very exciting that could be something
else uh this
uh i i hate to uh label any film
uh i think it's a crude uh a crude thing
to do but
as people are calling this a pop movie
they're saying it's a pop movie
uh and uh that guy's happy uh
uh and you've you've dealt with that
subject in some of your other
films do you smoke do you smoke pot do
you have personal knowledge of pot is
that what you're drawing on what a
terrible question to ask
yes yes i'm a bad bad man shocking yeah
uh i'm not a pot guy
uh because every time i ever smoked pot
i wind up you know
sucking on my hand in a corner going you
know when will it end when will it end
right now
it's not a fun experience for me no no
no i'm like a nyquil guy
hey man let's have some party and
michael texas yeah
so no i you know other people involved
in the movies seem to understand the
subject matter a little better than me
yeah yeah some of the actors seem i
can't really
say but they're on the screen yes
in major roles maybe it's ed begley i'm
not saying
yeah now uh why then make films about
potheads it's something that you seem to
be attracted to
well you know i'm not very smart
so i can only write for like dumb guys
i could only produce for dumb guys and
uh you know like i could never
write like goodwill hunting because you
know they play smart people and then i
would be like
then the smart guy says i don't know how
they talk
what do smart people say right right but
potheads i can do that all day long
right so it's a good thing now has your
family seen pineapple express
i know you have uh you know i have a
five-year-old daughter yes
and a ten-year-old daughter okay so will
they get to see this movie
you know i don't want them to right i
know that one day you know she's gonna
walk in the room and say
daddy i just smoked a j to your movie
pineapple express
right and that's not a good thing right
and she wants to see the movie she
hasn't seen any of the movies so yeah
you haven't see
your kids haven't seen any of your films
no no my daughter uh
mod she's 10. she's just doesn't
understand why she can't see the movies
in fact she wrote a letter
to you to beg you to force me
to let her see the movies uh i think
it's cool that she thinks i have that
kind of authority
she's literally like this is this real
yeah no she wrote a letter
because she uh she didn't understand why
she can't
the movies it says dear conan tell my
dad to let me see his movies
i haven't seen any even my friends can
see them it's not fair
i've already heard all the swear words
let's just say i hear my dad's friends
say them
i know what sex means and is
i love that sentence i know about the
clubs and drugs
i already know what's in my father's
movies why can't i see them
and then she lists the art movies she's
seen little miss sunshine
there's a grandpa doing heroin
then she says i saw the garden state at
the penguin store
while my dad spent two hours buying
shirts
that's kind of embarrassing yes i saw 15
minutes of there will be blood but then
i got scared and had to turn it off
and then she says so don't worry i'm not
going to do drugs and i'm not going to
dig for oil
[Laughter]
but what i am going to do is be a talk
show host
in japan one day just like oprah my hero
sorry conan
i can't believe i lost out to oprah
wow does that convince you at all you're
going to let her now
i really don't know like where is the
line of uh of what is uh
appropriate for kids i don't even want
my kids to know what i do for a living i
have like really young kids i don't want
them to know what i
just tell them i work in an insurance
company i do
yeah yeah no it's a it's a scary
business if you have kids i was just in
a comic-con yes comic-con the big comic
book
convention which has gotten huge and and
you went there how was that
i went there that's another one with my
kids which is you know scary i like
going there because everyone kind of
looks like me and smells like me
you know i see hey there's me if i dress
like han solo
right right there's me if i dress like
barbarella right and uh and you meet all
the people
that write about you on the message
boards because do they write nice things
about you on the message board
well every once in a while people you
know there's a little backlash just you
know when you have a lot of movies at
some point
people have to turn on you and then i
read the other day on the internet
someone's like judd apatows movies are a
fart to american culture
and went on and on and on and i felt bad
like i started feeling bad
and then i look who posted it and it
said danny glover's
blood
[Applause]
and that was not now should i believe
danny glover
does that invalidate his opinion no it
shouldn't invalidate his entire opinion
but because everything on the internet
like you got to realize like most of it
isn't real like most of the information
is bad
like according to wikipedia i can
pleasure myself orally that's what it
says on wikipedia yeah when in fact i
can
only barely reach it with the tip of my
tongue
i can feel my hot breath on it
there's a reason my children think i
work in insurance
should i let my daughter watch this
episode no no
uh now uh back to pineapple express for
the good of everybody
yeah uh this film i went blue there i
apologize this is like charlie rose
uh not uh you think this movie is not
just a pop movie you feel the the movie
has a message or you think this movie
doesn't have a message
well to me it has a message to me the
movie is about how bad your life gets
if you smoke marijuana and that the only
way they can quit smoking marijuana
is uh by having their drug dealers try
to murder them
right seth doesn't think it's anti-pot
at all he thinks i'm crazy seth rogen
thinks that it's a pro pop movie
uh he doesn't care
he just doesn't think it's anti-pop but
i think it's uh
now uh about your personal life uh your
your wife the beautiful lesley man has
been on this show
uh and she's a terrific and uh terrific
actress you uh
she's absolutely gorgeous how long have
you guys been married uh 11 years
11 years uh thank you i like people
always applaud that
i don't know we're one of the longest
lasting hollywood couples
that can't be true we're like jennifer
yes yes
um do you lap a towel lapita
yes i've heard that before i just saw a
laptop
they seemed happy and in love uh what's
it like you've been married 11 years
she's absolutely she's drop dead
gorgeous do you ever just pinch yourself
and say i
i can't believe i'm i'm married i don't
understand why she's there like
like every day for me is like a first
date like i just i'm uncomfortable i
feel like she's going to sneak out of
the restaurant at some point
i don't get it i know what you're saying
oh but she stays she stays no my wife
loves me she adores me
but you know there's moments in a
marriage where like you know you notice
your wife look at you
with that look that's like how did i
wind up with you
[Music]
how did this happen i dreamed of a
prince
i'm with a guy who can fart holes
through his underwear yeah
i wanted a perfect man and i have a guy
with so much hair on his back
i can see it in his shadow
[Laughter]
but it works you're happy
you